[Musique]
arrête c'est peut-être ta radio qui est
trop vieille comme ta musique
préhistorique
aujourd'hui on a une histoire un truc de
dingue
surtout des ados je sais que certaines
filles peuvent viser et comment ça
marche
attention
si c'est une seule fille j'aurais dit
que c'est une mutation aléatoire mais là
il y a des centaines de milliers de cas
je suis journaliste je veux raconter
votre histoire
donc ça va changer la donne
qu'est-ce que tu foutais le monde tel
qu'on le connaît
va changer radicalement
la plus sexy que j'ai jamais vu
écoutez si on l'a c'est parce qu'il nous
faut
pas de problème un petit sourire c'est
pas dur ah quand il serait TBG
il teste tout le monde je dois protéger
le monde
c'est intrusif contraire à l'éthique
dans nos enfants comme des criminels
moi ce n'est pas le sentiment que j'ai
elle a quelque chose de spécial
laisse-moi bosser pour toi
j'ai l'argent de mon père
je m'étais jamais aperçue que je vivais
constamment dans la peur j'ai envie de
voir le monde comme tu le vois mais le
géo m'a fait voir une autre possibilité
un monde qui serait meilleur pour nous
tous je me sens mille fois plus légère
et aussi mille fois plus forte
est-ce que tu imagines ce que c'est de
grandir aussi libre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]